Babylon 5 might not be dead after all it
could actually still make it to our
screens welcome to Sidetrack our Sci-Fi
TV and movie channel
[Music]
so a couple of months ago I did a video
and I was telling you that sources that
I speak to at Warner Brothers have told
me that Babylon 5 was dead that there
was absolutely no chance it was going to
be resurrected and we were not going to
be getting the reboot that J Michael
zazinski had promised us however now it
seems that there might have been a
change of plan now I've also also told
you in previous videos that it was
almost no chance that this was going to
be got onto the CW they've actually
Warner Brothers would really really like
Babylon 5 for HBO Max now that I mean
told is still the case
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that it's actually not necessarily
completely up to Warner Brothers the CW
have to relinquish Babylon 5 because
they actually do have contractually
speaking first dibs but Warner Brothers
would be making the TV show they own the
TV show they own Babylon 5. it's
completely up to them what happens to
the project moving forwards now Jane
micro susinski is still talking about
this a lot on Twitter he hoped to have a
decision months ago but we're still
waiting but why do not like little brown
things with its legs I do not like
anything with eight legs
will
except for the vinzini
but only because they are terrible at
cards something to do with compound eyes
I think I want this thing dead well the
reason is because of everything going on
at Warner Brothers Discovery it's been
well documented that a new CEO David
zaslaf just walked into a complete mess
at Warner Brothers he actually cut loads
and loads of projects
the main reason why is because Warner
Brothers is massively in debt I mean
seriously in debt they owe 50 billion
dollars and actually at the end of 2024
at least five billion dollars of that is
due to be repaid so they need to cut
costs now it's not just that though
that's been a bit of a problem at Warner
Brothers they've also wanted to change
the creative direction of
um lots and lots of projects I'm
actually told by several sources the
Batgirl the main reason why it was
dumped was not really Financial it was
creative it wasn't necessarily that it
was a bad film it was just continuing
Warner Brothers and the dceu down a path
that they no longer wanted to take
there you see this little trifle with a
centare
so even though they'd already spent
nearly 90 million dollars and it
wouldn't have actually cost a lot more
to get the movie to a position where it
could have at least gone on to HBO it
could have maybe got some of that money
returned they decided actually just to
completely scrap the project and move on
now the same really is going to be said
for Black Adam now by the time David
rosaslov came into his post Black Adam
was also virtually done and also you're
not going to scrap a project with the
rocking just on the off chance that it
makes a fortune but it didn't it didn't
do very well particularly and you know
it didn't exactly bomb at the box office
but it didn't actually explode it either
so the chances of us seeing the Black
Adam on the screens in the future is now
virtually nil we've also not going to be
seeing any more Henry Cavill Superman's
or several other Batman projects that
were being looked at
you are smaller
there are more of you there are more of
you now Warner Brothers are saying that
they have finished the call that there
is going to be no major projects
canceled going forwards and now we're
looking at some new exciting projects
and I think we're going to get to see a
real Direction very shortly on where
they're going with the Warner Brothers
and particularly for me where they're
going to be taken DC I think they're
going to be taking a slightly different
route and we might not see many of the
really big characters from DC Comics in
the future and they might focus on some
more of the Lesser characters but let's
see what happens
but going back to Babylon five so why is
it now being resurrected well according
to my sources it was never really dead
it was just pushed to the back burner
and looked like it would be
I swear they are evolving right before
my eyes
if you see something this big with eight
legs coming your way let me know
I'll kill it before it develops language
skills they had other much bigger fish
to fry and they weren't really concerned
with what was going on with Babylon 5 so
the project kind of got forgotten about
a little bit just for a few months but
now is back in and they are continuing
conversations apparently meetings will
be happening at some point in the very
near future with J micro sucinski and
the CW Now the CW network has been sold
itself next are the new owners of the
cwr really moving away from lots of
these quite expensive projects the
flashes in this last series were really
seeing the end of the arrowverse
entirely they have repeatedly said that
they would like to move more towards
sort of reality TV stuff that actually a
lot of people not me but a lot of people
do watch and it's actually incredibly
cheap to produce
so where does Babylon 5 really fit in
with that I would argue it doesn't but
on something like HBO Max oh hell that
could work now apparently as I said at
the start of the video Warner Brothers
don't have complete control over that
decision if the CW decide they're going
to take the Babylon 5 and they're going
to make a new show Warner Brothers will
make it and that's where it'll go and
Warner Brothers again I'm told will push
for it to appear on HBO Max at a later
date that is something that they've done
with other projects in the past
so
another option apparently according to
the source I've been speaking to and
again this is this their opinion but I
can't exactly tell you where they work
but they are close to the source
that actually one thing HBO Max would
like to do is maybe have a slightly
watered-down version that would go onto
the CW of Babylon 5 and then have sort
of like a director's cut of the same
series appear on HBO Max
so for example if it's an hour-long TV
show they're only generally like 40
minutes once you take the adverts out so
you could put something on the CW
there's say 40 45 minutes long put in
the advert still made sense but had a
lot of the you know like the darker
stuff maybe edited out or more heavily
edited
then you put the director's cut to the
full one hour episode on HBO Max so the
people in the CW get there what they
want and HBO Max get what they want and
to be honest for me I'm watching the HBO
Max
um director's cut version what I
actually want to see you know a bit of
swear and a bit of violence a bit of
what have you things that would be
watered down are taken out of the CW
version so so let's hope that this
project even though it looked like it
was dead as a door nail can be
resurrected like the Phoenix from the
flames and that we could get to see this
hard rebooted retelling of the Babylon 5
story with a modern twist
now I know that I'm going to get
comments saying that a modern telling of
the original story isn't necessary but J
Michael souzynski at the end of the day
wants to make this he wants to tell this
story and who are we to tell him he
can't so let's just see what Warner
Brothers HBO Max the CW decide and let's
see if we get Babylon 5 back on our
screens
please get in the comments and tell me
exactly what you think of this news is
this something you'd be excited by or is
this something you just go you know what
I'll just watch The Originals it was
better anyway
get in the comments and tell me exactly
what you think if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and you would never miss any of our new
videos also if you want to support the
channel and you enjoy the content
consider hitting the join Button as
always please stay safe and I'll see you
next time
[Music]